pour le moment il est tout feu tout
flamme en chemise
c'est d'artagnan l'a bien derrière elle
tape sur battront allez hop je suis une
femme je suis une française
mais je vois mal et leurs yeux vous avez
une troisième tête d'affiche
ilebo celui-là c'est votre candidat
enfin j'aimerais mieux un à chaque fois
qu'il passerait je regarderai
mbacké voler des gens peut-être que
l'humain que je défends tellement sera
au sommet de nos valeurs puisque le
monsieur 1 les verts présentent comme ça
et avec un représentant de l'être humain
alors oui c'est le champion des humains
voilà voilà et ensemble on aime mêler on
va pas par contre aura pas bouffer du
tofu
[Musique]
salle et gonfle peu mais on va continuer
à bouffer de la viande à boire des coups
[Musique]
thierry ardisson avait dit julien il
avait dit on en parlera tout à l'heure
il avait dit s'il fait moins de 7% de
part de marché du géant brillante et sms
matin jeudi je te confirme que bien une
cordiale il avait raté nous défoncer
partout louis
l'aspergent
[Rires]
pour prouver qu'il n'est pas extrême il
a employé un argument qu'on n'avait pas
entendu depuis nadine morano et son ami
noir
si vous tes revient dessus même bien
simplement que le jeu de la
dédiabolisation du rassemblement
national d'une personne donc on peut
dire autant qu'on veut qu'on n'est pas
extrême à partir du moment appartient à
un parti extrémiste ça restera un
goupillon photos de ma femme merci
bas quelques marine le pen quel service
public elle veut aujourd'hui en france
j'étais désolé est ce qu'on pourra
couper cette partie d'un pack ont
précédé son alors on peut pas couper
parce que c'est c'est pas possible
la politique est un métier le dimanche
24 avril 2022
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
vous avez recueilli 18 millions
six cent soixante dix huit mille
et
639 fois à nice à vous d'être de
marseille non oui c'est marseille vous
poser une question est ce que c'est vous
qui a dans le clip de l'algérino 2
on
m'a dit ça m'a fait beaucoup voilà
c'est un sosie
je connais mon mec que je crois qu'ils
n'hésitent pas tout cas les belges il la
vérité pas grave bah ouais plus dense
n'existe pas quoi faire du temps là elle
existe la bannette mais je peux pas tu
peux y aller elle est obligée question à
kampala moi je suis sûr qu'il nous ment
et cowboys avaient fait exprès tu peux
aller quoi de paris
[Applaudissements]
la victoire en chansons l'ukraine
triomphe à l'eurovision
631 points un score exceptionnel grâce
au soutien du public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tient à merci saliha break kia et marc
fauvelle pardon on n'avait pas vu qu'on
était de retour à l'antenne il est
quasiment à 9 heures sur france info
parce qu'il ya des réalités qui écrase
tout et qui s'impose à nous parce qu'il
ya des voies que nous nous devons
d'écouté
mesdames et messieurs avec nous en
direct de kiev le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky
[Applaudissements]
oui
merci
c'est vraiment très spécial d'être ici
et en plus ya pas de basse donc j'adore
j'adore kering belge vient d'interviewer
tombe
[Rires]
[Musique]
tous avouent l'appeler madame
c'est plus sûr
bercy
derrière ce
prénom âge sexe profession à quoi
ressemble le député type le profil type
de votre député en a évidemment un
screen et toute la précédente assemblée
est bien le candidat aux législatives à
une cinquantaine d'années et c'est un
homme bref le candidat type à une
prostate et surtout ils doivent bien
penser à cela faire palper tous les ans
dans le reste de l'actualité hier la
première ministre elisabeth borne était
en visite au muséum d'histoire naturelle
la visite de tous les dangers
une polémique la première minute a tenté
de relativiser elisabeth borgne
le fait celle-ci englobe
tout seul vincent dupas venir
m'embrasser où
c'est après ce qui s'est passé dans le
couple là c'était très émouvant le
baiser donc je vienne
ces formes suivez moi c'est bien connu
les français adorent la bande dessinée
il adore aussi chaussé patrick une bonne
il aime sauter cinq jours
[Rires]
et new haven sociaux
c'est avec du pain mais encore plus